I just want to say happy birthday John
me and my beard wanna wish you a happy
birthday happy happy birthday John Green
in honor of your birthday I'm going to
eat this Willie deep
despite its having permanent marker all
over it which I'm pretty sure
is not supposed to be edible hopefully I
don't die or anything
very very happy birthday happy birthday
John dftba for your birthday I have a
cake but it's not just any cake it's a
bubble so the nerdfighting puppy cake so
John happy birthday John good birthday
John happy birthday John happy birthday
John happy birthday John Murray wants to
say happy birthday - happy birthday John
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday control be made at all
[Music]
making muffins is kind of our thing so
in honor of John Day we've made John
muffins John you're a muffin
look there's a Hank and a Willie and
Yeti
Oh shucks you guys came out wrong put it
back you need to get John Green D F TV a
happy birthday John don't look that old
so happy birthday happy birthday John
Green never forget be awesome best
wishes
Margo Alaska and the Catherine's tonight
are having a tea party to celebrate such
an awesome day enjoy John this is for
you happy birthday happy birthday
when you said and you've got the guy the
world seems rough suck levels are high
just remember this one thing you could
do and it always works too
you gotta put stuff on your head you put
stuff on your head
will it be blue or it could be red
because matter if it's on your head and
touch your photo of wood you're out on
to your melon or fix the Christmas
talking to you Sarah bell only rule of
thumb is don't use a plastic bag because
that could go really wrong you gotta put
stuff on your head put stuff on your
head will it be blue or it could be red
Cal does matter it's on your head bounce
margaret's become on the top of your
crown soon you realize is no need to
brown try something harder and see just
how you do you'll find that it's true
you gotta put stuff on your head
you put stuff on your head will it be
blue or it could be red color doesn't
matter if it's on your head
and happy birthday for me lots of people
love you I think I bit off more than I
could chew I got over two hours of
footage which I cut down to nine minutes
it was way longer than I wanted to be
there was a lot of stuff that I was not
able to get in here which is why I don't
I'm making for you a comprehensive
collaboration that will have much more
footage of nerdfighters saying lots of
sweet and hilarious things to you and of
course blending and drinking birthday
cakes and I have to send out props with
a guy who blended a birthday cake and a
happy meal together because and there
are two more things that are gonna make
your birthday even better one is your
birthday present from the nerdfighters
and I to you John using the power of
nerdfighteria we have been able to make
you into a bobble head to your lifelong
dream of becoming a plastic figurine
with a head that wobbles back and forth
has finally been realized I had to get
500 of them made to get one made and
about all of them have already sold of
course we saved one for you and it will
be arriving at your house soon you are
welcome in the last thing that's gonna
make your birthday super awesome of that
some Dutch nerdfighters acquired for you
this clip the final of your birthday
collaboration happy birthday John who's
a Frank wants you to have a happy
birthday
so do I enjoy